[Music]
welcome everyone we are here at the dead
zone at the Pizza Authenticator app
Terry tell me what am I looking at here
I was promised pie all I see is pizza
what's what's going on it is a form of
pie right so we have an app here that
will authenticate pizza to a certain
region in the country right like we have
New York Pizza of California Pizza
Chicago pizza this app will judge how
authentic it is for what style it's
supposed to be okay interesting so uh
why don't you actually what do you show
us how it works so we have our pizza
here and we have our tablet here make
sure it's in focus and bam
and now Pizza Authenticator is judging
whether or not this pizza is authentic
so it's chewing on it and we see that it
is pretty confident that this is New
York style pizza and so definitely pizza
probably from New York okay okay let's
so let's check out this IV that's so
good looking fine there's more Midwest
so let's see
make sure it's in focus do it again he's
taking a bite out of that Chicago style
pizza
style so it's good all right now we'll
finish I'm curious to what testing these
things knows the hit knows what it is I
can't think of any pie that deserves to
have zucchini on it but yeah well here
in the wonderful Golden State's we make
abominations yes California yes so it
knew it was California pizza excellent
well I mean I'm a huge supporter of
anything that involves this amount of
pizza yeah but tell me what's the point
of this like why is this even a dead
zone oh we got this so this uses under
the covers mm right machine learning and
m/l is really daunting right like a lot
of people come to it like they think
they need to be as like a data scientist
to do it and you're rank and file
developer sometimes you know can't
approach it well we took kind of an
incredibly trivial use of ml and drained
it to like determine whether or not
pizza was authentic
and all of all of this we did like we
grabbed the data we classified all the
images it was all done by me who is an
app dev not a data scientist so it
really shows that anyone can do ml if I
can do it like anyone can do it so you
could take the same sort of technology
the same approach here and really apply
it to much more meaningful projects
right if you wanted to you know take
pictures of satellite pictures of
forests and see how they change over
time and see the identified trees from
the forest for the trees right like you
could do that with this and that's a
much more serious you know application
of this but it's the same principle
Pizza on the forest absolutely no and
it's it's a fun way to approach machine
learning that's sort of fantastic all
right now I believe the real pie is over
with mark so we're gonna we're gonna dig
into some of this so you pick your
favorite style piece so I'm gonna go for
the authenticated New York style and run
from the earth oh yeah it's it's it's
hard not to
so we'll dig into this and we're going
to cross over to you for dessert mark
[Music]